coup de théâtre au procès de maurice
papon mettre un mot parcelle dénonce la
parenté ans une victime qui a échappé à
la déportation et le président de la
cour d'assises
l'avalanche d or la femme du guide
témoigne elle comprend la douleur des
familles des victimes et considère que
la détention son mari est injustifiée la
fin du ramadan pour les musulmans un
bilan terrible pour l'algérie mille mans
en un mois victimes des terroristes
l'élection régionale des militants du
front national expriment clairement leur
opposition aux méthodes et aux discours
de leur président jean marie le pen
enquête dans ce journal les chinois
entre dans l'année du tigre 50 ans de
communisme ont laissé intacte une
tradition millénaire dans toute la chine
les pétards éclats madame monsieur
bonsoir coup de théâtre au procès de
maurice papon à bordeaux qui pose le
problème de savoir tout simplement si
les débats pourront aller jusqu'au bout
en effet l'avocat le plus turbulent des
parties civiles maître arno klarsfeld a
révélé qu'un membre de la famille de
jean louis castagnettes président de la
cour d'assises avait échappé un convoi
de déportation dont maurice papon aurez
la responsabilité a priori l'avocat
n'avait aucun intérêt à donner des
arguments la défense
mais ce coup de théâtre peut également
en cacher un autre françois privat
philippe dumas dans un instant le
reportage de france ti gais et tendu
jean-louis castagnède le président des
assises de la gironde a choisi de garder
les rênes du procès papon beaucoup plus
médiatique
arno klarsfeld dans un rôle d'accusateur
l'avocat affirme que jean-louis
castagnède aurait un lien de parenté
avec une famille dont la déportation est
reproché à maurice papon
il somme le magistrat d'abandonner le
procès en septembre a eu toute sa
famille de porter par maurice papon
donc on peut se poser des questions il y
aura forcément un doute qui planera sur
le
dernier le front des autres avocats de
parties civiles
il accuse arno klarsfeld de vouloir
saboter le procès quand on réfléchit sur
la raison qui a pu motiver
arno klarsfeld et sans doute aussi son
père car nous personne ne fait rien sans
une décision de son père on ne voit
qu'une seule réponse la volonté de
casser ce procès aujourd'hui une
audience courte 45 minutes
il ne s'est rien passé mais surprise
arno klarsfeld
étrangement silencieux n'a pas demandé
la récusation du président castagnet
tant que maître au barreau et le façon
ne le fasse pour lui fallait attendre
combien de temps moins que ce même si
l'hypothèse d'arno klarsfeld étaient
vérifiées dans les faits ça ne
changerait rien pour la défense qui
réitère l'hommage qu'elle rend à
l'impartialité à la neutralité du
président castagnettes donc ça ne
changerait rien pas question de
récusation pour les avocats de maurice
papon qui ne cachent pas leur
satisfaction colère en revanche des
parties civiles
je ne connais pas l'objectif de monsieur
arno karsfeld et je vous dirais qu est
la limite
j'attends ses explications chine et
donne très bien si les deux baba qui se
sent morveux qui se mouche plus tard
julian benzion partie civile confirme
tout de même le lien de parenté du
président castagnède avec la famille b
nay
je ne savais même pas que cette cousine
de mon père était barre yann castagnède
se croyait que non là j'ai eu des
confirmations
la polémique suspicion on est loin de ce
qui devait être un procès historique de
cette affaire dans la sphère il n'en a
donc pas été question officiellement
aujourd'hui au cours des débats qui ont
été reportés à lundi il faut dire que ce
procès qui traîne en longueur n'en est
pas à son premier coup d'éclat depuis le
début bien les choses se sont mal
engagées dominique verdeilhan dominique
un procès pour l'histoire un procès pour
l'exemple un procès exemplaire c'était
le 8 octobre le souhait de tous ceux qui
participaient qu'il attendait depuis 16
ans mais trois jours plus tard le monde
entier découvre cette image inattendue
maurice papon est libre la vie de
château d'un homme jugé pour crimes
contre l'humanité
stupeur des victimes incompréhension de
certains de leurs avocats ce jour là
arnaud perçu elle décide de partir en
guerre contre le président castagnède
déjà l'avocat met en doute la partialité
du magistrat et depuis trois mois les
incidents se multiplient entre les deux
hommes
durant les audiences mais déjà le procès
ces gars se trompe d'époque on juge
papon pour les événements de 1961 quand
l'homme était préfet de police les
victimes ont le sentiment que le procès
leur échappe
homme politique historien défilent à la
barre chant des partisans alterne avec
couplet des détracteurs les faits n'ont
toujours pas été abordé quand maurice
papon doit être hospitalisé
remy papon se fait combatif face aux
accusations il souligne les lacunes de
l'instruction après 16 ans de procédure
chaque partie verse un nouveau document
et fait entendre des témoins de l'époque
que la justice n'a jamais auditionné pro
tardif
leurs témoignages perdent de leur force
très attendu très craint michel bergès
l'homme qui en 80 accuse papon l'homme
qui en 81 18 plaide pour l'accusé michel
bergès fait part de ces incertitudes
historiens pour moi dit il l'enquète
continue 57 audiences ont mis en lumière
les absents du box rené bousquet le
préfet le chef du service des questions
juives tous morts dans 20 ans le film du
procès pourra être visionné six mois
d'archives/reuters et qui restera le
plus long mais le plus confus de
l'histoire judiciaire
on direct avec nous à bordeaux dominique
verdeilhan sérieusement dominique le
procès peut il s'interrompt écoutez nous
avons quand même assisté aujourd'hui à
quelque chose qu'il faut bien qualifier
d' hypocrisie comme si de rien ne
s'était passé le procès pour crimes
contre l'humanité deux dents et un
procès d'intention dehors alors devant
les accusations de juge et partie le
président pouvait très bien quitter son
fauteuil cela n'aurait pas compromis la
suite du procès il aurait été remplacé
par un juge suppléant
mais le président veut rester et laisse
en quelque sorte arno karsfeld face à
ses responsabilités et arnaud cassel et
son père serge et bien vol récusé le
magistrat y veulent son départ
c'est une procédure rare exceptionnelle
et si elle allait jusqu'au bout s'il
était mis en marche
et bien cela ralentirait encore un peu
plus ce procès sans fin
rappelons simplement que lors de la mise
en liberté de maurice papon
arno klarsfeld avait quitté l'audience
en disant qu'il quitte elle procèdera
jours plus tard il revenait
résultat quand même ce soir maurice
papon est passée au second plan
d'ailleurs il a rejoint ce soir son
domicile de la région parisienne
le président du conseil constitutionnel
roland dumas est il impliqué dans une
affaire de commissions occultes à propos
d'un important marché d'armes vers
taïwan l'intéressé reste muet ses
avocats font savoir qu'ils se
considèrent comme étranger à cette
affaire de leur côté des juges en charge
du dossier continuent leur enquête et
leurs perquisitions livé caroff benoît
gallerey c'est dans cette agence
parisienne que se trouvent les comptes
en banque de roland dumas des comptes
sur lesquels de nombreuses opérations
bancaires ont été effectués en
particulier par une avocate proche du
président du conseil constitutionnel
elle aussi était cliente dans cette
agence elle avait surtout une
procuration ou retirer et déposer de
l'argent sur les comptes de roland dumas
la brigade financière l'a longuement
interrogé hier sur les nombreux
versements en espèces constatés par les
enquêteurs dès somme de 250 mille francs
parfois d'un demi million l'un de ces
versements atteindrait même huit cent
mille francs des mouvements qui à
l'époque avait déjà intrigué
la direction du crédit lyonnais mais en
passant ainsi au crible ces mouvements
bancaires qui pourrait frôler les 10
millions de francs laurence vichnievsky
eva joly cherche à établir un lien
financier entre roland dumas est l'une
de ses amies
christine deviers-joncour incarcéré
depuis novembre par les deux juges
d'instruction
elle aurait perçu une commission sur une
vente d'armes françaises à taïwan 45
millions de francs versés par une
vieille connaissance du joli alfred
sirven
l'homme est au coeur de la monumentale
affaire elf
pendant longtemps il a dirigé les
affaires générales du groupe pétrolier
puis on le retrouve en suisse où il
dirige une filiale d'elf
mais il vit toujours à genève et ce dans
le même immeuble que cette filiale en
tout cas jusqu'à l'été dernier
l'un de ses émissaires donne alors
rendez-vous à christine deviers-joncour
dans cet hôtel elle doit lui remettre 20
millions de fonds depuis alfred sirven
est introuvable
la justice française c'est simplement
que malgré un mandat d'arrêt
international lancé contre lui
il a obtenu le très protecteur statut de
résidents helvétiques
il ya une semaine neuf collégiens et
deux adultes ont été tués dans une
avalanche à la station des orres dans
les hautes-alpes
depuis seul le guide de haute montagne
responsable de la randonnée a été mis en
examen et incarcéré préventivement
aujourd'hui nous avons rencontré sa
femme qui accepte pour la première fois
de témoigner l'importer est bien
conscient du drame mais elle estime que
la mise en détention de son mari est
injuste vincent guyenne vincent youf
arctique pour fuir les médias hélène
forte est allé vivre chez des amis mais
aujourd'hui elle nous accueille pour
exprimer sa douleur son mari est en
prison et elle en dessous elle ne
l'avait pas fait avant par décence pour
les familles
avant toute chose elle a tenu à nous
faire part du témoignage de sympathie
de la mère d'une des victimes on m'a
même demandé de citer le nom de son fils
jean baptiste
sa mémoire
parce qu'elle m'a dit que c'est c'était
pire pour moi que pour elle mais mais
c'est faux parce que je sais je sais je
sais bien que c'est pas vrai c'est bien
c'était que le pire c'est de père de
l'enfant
ce que mon mari s'en sortira elle est
allée le voir hier à la maison d'arrêt
de gars ensemble ils n'ont pas évoqué la
faire juste quelques nouvelles
madame forte ne nous a pas dit si son
mari se sentait responsable de quoi que
ce soit elle a préféré évoquer la
passion d'un homme
il avait 20 ans 19 20 et moi j'avais 15
ans ont commencé à grimper en forme avec
le club alpin d'aix-en-provence et est
depuis sa passion et n'a eu envie de la
faire vivre la faire vivre aux autres et
à 24 ans elle a quitté le métier qui
faisait travailler en industrie il a
fait pour faire une une formation alex
pella et passer ses diplômes et sa
deuxième pour man de montagne et toutes
les femmes de guidel vous le diront
exactement comme avec ses hellions et le
savez savez que les mamans
beaucoup d'amis qu'il s'en fait piéger
un vous enfant je n'aurais jamais caché
espaces et on a essayé surtout de les
protéger pour parquets pour qu'ils
apprennent en douceur quoi c'est pas
facile hein de mendiants et enfants
mon père est né en prison qu'est-ce
qu'il a fait là bas on a confiance et
surtout tous les deux en simple très
fort et par parent acté en prêt dans
cette eau
le brouillard à l'origine d'un
carambolage meurtrier sur une auto belge
proche de la frontière française dans la
région de courtrai huit morts dans un
enchevêtrement de tôle et la circulation
bloquée pendant plusieurs heures toute
cette journée à nemours dominique maes
les véhicules sont imbriqués les uns
dans les autres les voitures
déchiquetées de ces amas de ferraille
les secouristes belges ont retiré dix
corps dont celui d'un enfant dé 10
heures 15 ce matin sur l'autoroute la
circulation est dense
la visibilité quasi nulle sur près de
400 m un gigantesque carambolage
il était pas que la rouge est venu se
taper sur la rouge n'ai rien fait non
c'était trop bu et tous ceux qui nous
suivent et août été emboutie dans le
camion il ya les dumas l'appui des morts
dans le cadre est débout c'est tout ce
qui est alors l'un derrière l'autre
qu'on était dehors qu'on entend dès sa
rentrée
de plus en plus notamment l'un dans
l'autre et des voitures et des coupes
seront chauffés les rescapés indemme air
de longues minutes avant d'être pris en
charge
au total une centaine de véhicules sont
impliqués à l'origine du carambolage
un épais brouillard mais aussi la
vitesse excessive
c'est une autoroute très fréquentée et
en belgique je crois qu ailleurs aussi
les camions sont limitées à 90 km/heure
ce qui veut dire que généralement il
roule à cette vitesse là c'est
naturellement une vitesse qui entendent
brouillard nous poser des problèmes il y
a deux ans quasiment au même endroit
avec le même brouillard
un accident similaire avait déjà fait 10
morts aujourd'hui cette autoroute a une
nouvelle fois mérité son surnom
d'autoroute de la mort les écologistes
considéreront sans doute comme une
victoire le projet du gouvernement qui
envisage d'augmenter le prix de la
vignette des voitures diesel moins taxé
que l'essence le prix du gasoil à la
pompe pourraient également suivre cette
décision concernerait les véhicules
mises en service à partir du 1er juillet
prochain accord dans la fonction
publique pour une hausse des salaires de
2 6% pour 98 et 99 seules la cgt et la
fsu n'ont pas signé cet accord concerne
8 millions de fonctionnaires actifs
retraités des hausses supplémentaires
sont prévus pour les bas salaires et
pour la première fois le ministre de la
fonction publique emile zuccarelli a
évoqué la possibilité de l'application
des 35 heures par semaine pour les
salariés de l'état
justement en pleine discussion
parlementaire sur la semaine des 35
heures lionel jospin a décidé d'appuyer
son gouvernement en entreprenant un
déplacement dans l'oise dans une
entreprise qui appliquent déjà la loi de
robien de réduction du temps de travail
ce qui fait dire à gilles de robien
justement que le premier ministre fait
preuve de malhonnêteté intellectuelle en
se servant d'une loi pour en faire
passer une autre reportage laurent
bailly et patrice x une visite imprévue
décidé en catastrophe serait ce l'effet
des mauvais sondages
lionel jospin en tout cas a voulu monter
en première ligne dans le débat sur les
35 heures alors qu'il se déplace sur le
terrain accompagnés en l'occurrence de
martine aubry avec qui il veut afficher
sa proximité dans cette entreprise de
600 salariés grâce à la loi de robien
on va réduire le temps de travail est
recruté 80 personnes bref c'est
l'exemple parfait qui doit démontrer à
l'opinion selon le premier ministre que
les 35 heures ça marche était nécessaire
que vous puissiez témoigner par par des
images par des signes de cette réalité
d'une réduction du temps de travail qui
se fait dans des outils performants sans
handicaper l'entreprise comme certains
le prétendent
un message que lionel jospin adresse
directement aux chefs d'entreprise
martine aubry elle se charge en ce
moment de le répéter chaque jour à
l'assemblée nationale voyage de jacques
chirac à mulhouse pour le 200e
anniversaire du rattachement de la ville
à la france mulhouse connaître une forte
communauté immigrée
le président en a profité pour redéfinir
les voix de l'intégration mais il a
aussi déclaré que l'emploi était la
véritable réponse à l'exclusion
reportage véronique salive jean corne
exaltation de la nation costumes d'il ya
deux cents ans quand mulhouse demandait
son rattachement à la france
c'est dans ce décor d'opérette que le
chef de l'état a saisi l'occasion de
donner sa vision de l'intégration
réussie
aujourd'hui mulhouse avec 20 % de sa
population d'origine étrangère 15 % de
taux de chômage est aussi pour le front
national une terre d'élection
alors dans ce contexte nouveau
grossissant des difficultés actuelles du
pays
jacques chirac s'est attaché à relier
l'intégration à l'emploi et sans évoquer
directement les mesures dette envisagé
par le gouvernement le président de la
république a délivré son propre
diagnostic ces femmes et ces hommes que
les mutations de l'économie ont parfois
rejetées aux confins extrême de notre
société
ce n'est pas seulement une assistance
financière qu'ils réclament c'est
participer eux aussi à la création des
richesses
on accompagne pas à pas leur retour vers
l'emploi
et comme pour illustrer son appel à la
cohésion nationale
jacques chirac avant de repartir pour
paris s'est attardé longuement dans les
salons de l'hôtel de ville avec la
championne du monde de natation d'eau
elle s'appelle roxana mari jean yahoo
elle est d'origine roumaine aujourd'hui
elle est française à elle seule elle est
tout un symbole
les élections régionales auront lieu en
mars un sondage ipsos le point indique
que les français votent reste à 43% pour
la majorité 36% pour l'opposition 14 %
pour le front national 5% pour les
écologistes 2% pour l'extrême gauche
régionales toujours pour la première
fois de manière aussi marquée frappante
une élection provoque de re des remous
sérieux au sein du front national des
dissidents n'hésite pas à se manifester
pour dire qu'ils ne sont pas d'accord du
tout avec les méthodes et le discours de
leur président jean marie le pen enquête
michaël darmon et guillaume soula
je n'ai plus peur
la musique entraîne la salle du palais
des congrès de lyon mais les paroles ne
correspondent pas tout à fait à la
réalité car le président du front
national cause plutôt des soucis à
nombre de cadres locaux en pleine
préparation des élections régionales
samedi 24 janvier ses élus de mulhouse
et du haut-rhin annoncent leur démission
ils seront neuf à partir conseillers
municipaux ou comme i'll do that you
conseiller régional sortant
écarté des listes lui n'accepte pas les
investitures parachuté dit il par
jean-marie le pen donc constater que ce
sont les étrangers fraîchement parachute
et qu'ils prennent une décision sans
consulter sa c'est particulièrement
humiliant cette amertume et a priori
banal quand on sait que les places sont
très convoitées dans les conseils
régionaux
mais autour de cette table ces vieux
militants expriment aussi un malaise
plus profond
après les propos de jean marie le pen il
ya des des choses qu'on ne peut pas
accepter et illange reviennent en
revient toujours au même un truc j'ai eu
déjà de langnau sur le pen qui ne
passent qu'une phase et avant une
élection à chaque pas comme avant les
législatives
qu est ce qui ressort le détail vivent à
munich pour faire quoi ou discréditer le
front national parce que c'est pas
possible je ne serais pas étonné qu'il y
ait des effets de boules de neige je ne
serais pas étonné nous avons des coups
de fil qu'on a reçu deux collègues
d'autres une fédération qui dans le fond
on n'attendait qu'un des taux nets
restée jusque-là chuter rennes une
colère de la base contre la direction
nationale se propage à travers
l'appareil du fn ces derniers mois autre
mois avant de recevoir une réponse
dans le tarn et garonne par exemple
plusieurs responsables ont rendu leur
carte
après le maintien en place d'un
dirigeant local condamné pour
détournement de fonds dans une affaire
privée
je suis prêt à travailler avec beaucoup
de gens à partir du moment où on a les
mêmes objectifs mais des gens qui ont
été condamnés ou des gens qui
soutiennent en quelqu'un qui a été
condamné par la justice française doit
être exclu je ne peux pas soutenir les
pères de ces personnes là ce jour là
bernard antony chef de file du fn en
midi-pyrénées minimiser la crise dans
cette région soixante deux petites
choses pour nous en avait partout c'est
une bonne génération mais il ya toujours
quelques aigris la bataille des
investitures n'explique pas tout fait
nouveau front national des cadres locaux
hausse élevée ouvertement contre le mode
de gestion et les propos de jean marie
le pen
on l'a vu dans les coulisses de la
convention des candidats à lyon ici ce
groupe venu de l'hérault proteste auprès
de bruno mégret contre un parachutage de
saint cloud et eliane de labrosse maire
adjoint de toulon dénonce l'investiture
à sa place de sandrine chevalier les
pousses du maire travaille mes problèmes
des roues le vaucluse la mayenne le var
à chaque fois les cadres se rebiffent
contre les décisions des chefs parisiens
au point que dans son discours à lyon le
président du front national a dû taper
du poing sur la table
désormais la bataille est commencé et il
ne sera plus admis aux réclamations
n'est non plus d'aigreur front national
à mon avis de randy mal et du fait de
grands dirigeants ni mal il ya une
tentative de 2-2-2 santé l'esprit du
mouvement sur une position dure et faute
prise de croissance ou nouvelle étape
dans les luttes de succession au fn
toujours est il que depuis quelques
jours l'encouragent jean marie le pen
l'alertent sur ces rébellion interne des
tensions qui confirme un phénomène
récent
le front national est en train de
s'émanciper de son chef historique très
bien de bourg en bresse le procureur de
la république a requis quatre ans de
prison huit cent mille francs d'amendé à
l'encontre de robert bourachot l'ancien
président de la société de travaux
publics maya et duclos principal prévenu
d'un procès qui a mis à jour un réseau
de fausses factures destinées à des
partis politiques sans qu'aucun
destinataires des fonds n'était est
clairement identifié l'actualité
internationale c'est la fin du ramadan
pour les musulmans en algérie cette
période de fraternité de paix aura été
au contraire marqué par une sauvage et
redoubler de la part des terroristes
mille morts c'est le bilan officieux de
ces 30 jours près d'alger dans un petit
village la fin du ramadan n'a pas été
comme par le passé fêté par toute une
série de réjouissance la population plus
que jamais sur ces gars mais un peu plus
rassuré tout même depuis que les hommes
du village ont été armés jérôme bunny
jean-françois rue reportage à chebli
depuis plusieurs années la fête de l'aïd
n'est plus ce qu'elle était les
traditions sont là las la bia le gâteau
de rupture du jeûne les vêtements neufs
pour les enfants mais le coeur n'y est
pas par ailleurs les alentours immédiats
de chebli sont un des fiefs du
terrorisme algérien qui a fait un
millier de victimes depuis le début du
ramadan longtemps les groupes armés ont
traversé impunément
cette ancienne ferme coloniale on était
deux hommes avant qu'ils partent bien
sûr un habiter ensemble ils sont
originaires d'ici maintenant eh bien on
est armé on en prend peur qu'il vient
n'importe quel moment en les enfants au
début du ramadan ces villageois armés
ont réussi à repousser une attaque
nocturne dans le bourg les murs sont
couverts d'avis de recherche de tête
mise à prix avec et sans ballon
la garde communale a été renforcée de
nouveaux volontaires
c'est grâce à leur présence que beaucoup
d'habitants ont retrouvé leurs maisons
après plusieurs années d'exil cette
famille n'avait pas fêté l'aïd chez elle
depuis trois ans la mini la lune ya bien
ici âgées les opérations des forces de
sécurité sont de l'avoir quelque peu
désorganisé les réseaux clandestins
d'artificiers d'après la presse
algérienne depuis le début des attentats
à la bombe qui ont coïncidé avec la
visite de la délégation européenne au
début de la semaine dernière il y aurait
plus de morts parmis les poseurs de
bombes
il disait nantes où le juge
antiterroriste jean louis bruguière a
définitivement bouclé son dossier
d'instruction sur la catastrophe du
dc-10 du thé à brazzaville paris qui
avait fait 170 mans c'était en 1989 huit
ans dans lequel une certitude ce sont
les services secrets libyens qui sont à
l'origine de l'attentât
on marche de ces gros problème un petit
ennui pour le président clinton sur un
aéroport de l'état de l'illinois son
avion air force one s'est embourbé au
décollage l'appareil a quitté la piste
le président a dû emprunter un autre
avion mais avec le sourire
pas de nouvelles informations dans les
démêlés de bill clinton dans la sphère
monica levinsky en revanche les
américains ont l'impression de revivre
aux journées en réalité ce qu'ils ont
déjà pu voir au cinéma dans plusieurs
films sortis ces derniers mois des
scénario presque identique à la sphère
actuelle washington philippe gassot
ce qui fascine l'amérique et le
phénomène s'amplifie c'est l'homme le
plus puissant de la terre qui donne des
balles ou qui danse comme au cinéma sur
un air de nat king cole à la maison
blanche
il règne depuis le salon ovale sur
l'amérique et sur le monde bill clinton
même les acteurs ils aiment hollywood il
aime le cinéma
et quand on le rencontre avec michael
douglas on ne sait plus très bien qui
joue quoi spielberg et ses amis à
supporters michael jackson aussi
et si le monde du spectacle aime bien
bill clinton l'univers du cinéma se
nourrit de plus en plus de la chair des
présidents je pense que l'on vit une
époque
oui l'heure de la mode de s'attaquer aux
symboles de la société alors jusqu'à un
certain point ça va mais on doit pas
oublier que nous avons malgré tout un
remarquable système de gouvernement
le cinéma braquent sur la maison blanche
et sur son locataire ses objectifs avec
d'autant plus de délectation que la vie
privée du président donne prise dernier
film en date
wag the dog en d'autres termes noyer le
poisson et il prémonitoire
c'est en fait l'histoire d'un président
qui pour masquer ses débordements
amoureux détourner l'attention de la
presse déclenché une guerre contre
l'albanie
vous produisez douce vous voulez que je
produise votre guerre dans la réalité
bill clinton mena saddam hussein de
riposte le même jour la dernière
embrassades du président avec monica est
diffusé sur toutes les télés dans le
film couleurs primaires on croirait voir
bill clinton et salon ovale torride dans
pouvoir absolu il est bien évident que
toute ressemblance avec des personnes
existantes ou ayant existé serait
purement fortuite
et dans la réalité maintenant le
secrétaire d'état américain à madeleine
albright est à paris pour tenter de
convaincre la france qu'il faut opérer
une frappe militaire sur l'irak qui
continueraient de dissimuler
d'importantes quantités d'armements
échappant au contrôle des nations une la
france est plus que réticente mais les
américains bien décidés sans plus
agir même seul un français dans l'espace
depuis un peu plus de trois heures
maintenant léopold eyharts s'est
embarqué à bord d'une fusée russe
destination la station mir sur place
romain leblanc claude sicard pas une
seconde de retard sur le programme
comme à l'habitude ici avec ono à 17
heures 33 minutes 40 secondes précises
heure française soyouz s'est arraché des
steaks glacial du kazakhstan et pourtant
la tante aura été bien longue pour le
cosmonaute français léopold eyharts en
août dernier il aurait dû se glisser
comme aujourd'hui dans son scaphandre
pour rejoindre la route des étoiles mais
au dernier moment du matériel de secours
est parti à sa place c'était l'été des
catastrophes en série dans la station
spatiale russe un incendie une collision
des pannes informatiques
une histoire oubliée ou presque pour les
pousses du français oublier toutes ces
incidents devenir quoi oui oui et non
on y pense toujours pas ce qu'elle veut
alors je serais quand même contente que
l'atterrissage à 12 heures de travail
quotidien pendant 19 jours à bord de
mire le planning du français sera chargé
pour lui il faudra renouveler les
expériences scientifiques que la
française le deviendrait drv réalisée
l'été 96
que ce soit des la médecine il va
observer comment se comporte le corps
dans l'espace que ce soit de la physique
des matériaux il va observer comment se
déploient des matériaux
ça va nous permettre de faire mieux que
ça va nous permettre de mieux connaître
comment tout cela se passe dans l'espace
le séjour des bleus russes ne sera pas
de tout repos non plus ils seront quatre
mois pour tenter de colmater le module
spectre là où le français aurait dû
mener ses expériences en laboratoire
rendu inutilisable depuis la première
collision de l'espace
c'est le nouvel an en chine et selon
leur calendrier nous attaquons l'année
du tigre d'une tradition
particulièrement vivace que nous avons
suivie dans une petite localité qui a
gardé vous et loire intact un décor d'un
autre âge portage isabelle bechler
tristan loy et miiaou est une sorte
d'oasis dans la chine de la course au
progrès la vie et série ton quasi
immuable à minuit ont su sera des
bonbons pour que l'année soit douce et
il faudra chasser les mauvais esprits
avec des guirlandes de pétards shawty
cinquième fils de la famille et du signe
du tigre et ils se chargent des derniers
achats avec quelques enfants de la tribu
de laguiole 72 ans au petit dernier
trois mois la famille contre 89 membres
depuis des siècles c'est la lumière qui
fait le nouvel an pour saluer les dieux
les maisons se pare de lanterne rouge
couleur du bonheur qu'on appelle de ses
voeux
nous les frères nous sommes toujours
très respectueux à l'égard de notre mère
comme nos enfants le sont de nous c'est
la fête de la famille l'apa sont
toujours avec notre mère à pignan
confucius est chez lui
les mâles font l'honneur de la famille
pour chacun des fils un papier découpé
avec l'idéogramme de son nous on donne
même la becquée à la grand mère pour lui
signifier que la piété filiale la
tiendra à l'abri du besoin
c'est elle qui est à l'honneur chacun
mange les nouilles qui figurent le lien
entre les deux années les fils boivent
en hommage à leur mère et se livrent à
des joutes verbales sous son arbitrage
ils sont tous là pour la fête ils sont
adorables
ils sont tous si respectueux ça me fait
vraiment très plaisir
dad
le communisme a eu beau tenter
d'éradiquer le respect des anciens et
les rites qui l'accompagnent ce principe
confucéen reste une constante de la vie
sociale tout comme la recherche de la
prospérité
j'espère gagner beaucoup d'argent en
cette année du tigre
tous nos amis étrangers sont les
bienvenus pour développer le tourisme et
investir à pia cette bourgade du 14e
siècle vient d'être inscrite au
patrimoine architectural de l'humanité
par l'unesco
autant dire un vrai potentiel
touristique dès que les lignes
électriques auront été enterrés et
l'infrastructure améliorée grâce aux
crédits internationaux on fera donc
crier les pétards pour cette prospérité
annoncé car l'année du tigre devrait
être bénéfique
il reste à laguiole protéger ses
descendants du cygne à l'aide de ses
ceintures rouges
les tigres sont forts et mordant
courageux face à l'adversité et ils ont
toujours confiance en eux tout comme pin
yahoo a confiance en ses traditions pour
changer son avenir
les pet a également peut-être cette nuit
à partir de 3h prendre vous pourrez
suivre sur france 2 en direct la demi
finale des internationaux de tennis
d'australie entre le français nicolas
escudé le chili à rios escudé n'est pas
favori faut bien le dire mais tout est
possible il y croit il est en grande
forme sur place en australie
lionel chamoulaud nicolas escudé signe
des autographes à tour de bras normal il
est devenu une véritable attraction ici
ce qui est plus étonnant c'est qu'il
signe de la main gauche lorsqu'il jouait
au tennis ballon lui qui a bien failli
devenir footballeur professionnel comme
papa tape du pied gauche
en revanche quand il jouait au tennis il
est droitier et ils frappent tellement
bien du bras droit qu'il est seulement
le troisième français en 70 ans a joué
une demi finale de l'open d'australie
historique mais pas de quoi l'empêcher
de dormir ou le sommet facilement par un
match aussi particuliers ont été
vraiment très très fatiguée je
ce détachement cette décontraction fait
le bonheur d'eric deblicker qui super
tarik benhabilès l'entraîneur habituel
de nicolas qui restaient en france mais
je crois que c'est très très bien il
reste lui-même il et il est simple et
naturelle et je crois que c'est la
meilleure chose qui puisse y arriver
bien qu'il ait dû à trois reprises
disputé des matches en cinq sets la
suite est une demi-finale de grand
chelem pour lui un match normal tu le
prends comme les autres je vais faire le
maximum je préparais communes comme si
je jouais 2 100e joueur mondial
je me suis rassis de la tête gérer
complètement déjoué
you will a joué en juniors je crois que
c'était à roland-garros si j'avais perdu
en beauté l'année dernière à la même
époque nicolas étaient 400 13e au
classement atp il va désormais entrer
dans le clan des 35 meilleurs du monde
ça change tout retour sur le grand
événements d'hier soir linkedin
inauguration du stade de france à
saint-denis
ne boudons pas notre plaisir pour une
fois tout le monde est content vraiment
content florent gautreau philippe
deslandes
ça de 4000 spectateurs ainsi à sauver
aussi de marseille qui nous attendent
aussi se sentent aimés les spectateurs
donc mais on sent un engouement et c'est
plaisant de jouer devant 80000 personnes
surtout en france quoi finalement
quand vous rentrez dans une arène comme
ça vous avez envie de jouer au football
vous enviez envie de participer
on voit très bien vous était vraiment
génial je crois que c'est une chose
qu'il faut avoir vu au moins une fois
dans sa vie
c'est magnifique c'est extraordinaire on
a passé un moment merveilleux et plus
devraient y travailler n'était
disparition de la doyenne des
comédiennes françaises qui demeurait en
activité mu d'albret 94 ans elle avait
commencé sa carrière au théâtre en 1923
au cinéma elle fut une héroïne de jean
renoir et de maurice pialat dans le film
nous ne vieillirons pas ensemble
cinéma justement dernières sorties de la
semaine le film du cinéaste allemand wim
wenders the end of violence la fin de la
violence le réalisateur entend dénoncer
le cinéma qui montre la violence pour la
violence mais lui-même renonce à toute
image de violence
pour réaliser cette démonstration
reportage au brier de l'air christian
bîmes wenders garde son allure
particulière de rêveur un peu timide
mais toujours attentif lui peut-être le
plus européen des cinéastes revient
aujourd'hui à la mairie une s'y
interroge cette fois sur la violence
celle que crée l'argent
l'égoïsme et le cinéma érigé en business
tout commence à los angeles bien sûr le
luxe est omniprésente
le producteur richissime mais plus
apparente est semble-t-il ont reçu 1
quel humain son but faire des films
violence et vulgarité rapporte au gros
son univers un ordinateur pour tout
interlocuteur bien
les nîmois
parce que tous les films par la violence
aujourd'hui on peut pas aller au cinéma
sans être confronté avec la violence
mais finalement c'est de moins en moins
ce que c'est parce qu'il est filmé en
parle et nous montre la violence mais
nous font rarement comprendre ce que
c'est dans ce film policier l'atmosphère
étrange los angeles est la vedette
la ville truffée de caméras de
surveillance semble victime de la
violence qu'elle imagine et utilise
fustigeant les esprit mercantile du
cinéma bîmes wenders poursuit sa
réflexion sans coup de force ni le bluff
sur le pouvoir des images dans notre
société on nous quittait le rappel des
principaux titres de l'actualité de ce
jeudi d'abord le kenya pour procès papon
m
arno karsfeld dénonce la pas rentrer en
chine victime qui a échappé à la
déportation et le président d'eads
insiste jean-louis castagnède le
brouillard à l'origine d'un carambolage
meurtrier sur une autoroute belge près
de la frontière française dans la région
de courtrai 8 morte dans un
enchevêtrement de tôle
la circulation a repris ce soir dans un
instant la météo sophie davant puis le
point route
valérie maurice 20h50 envoyé spécial le
magazine de la rédaction paul nahon et
bernard benyamin demain 7h 50 dans les 4
vérités
françoise laborde recevra emmanuel todd
historien et politologue
et puis demain soir ici même vous
retrouverez béatrice schönberg je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée sur notre
chaîne bonsoir